ahead just where is it
the Sun
is that it can you talk Gary
yo
yeah yeah
are you sure
yeah
everything we just said was muted dude
we're geniuses
we should have probably checked before
we went live yeah well we have Kyle over
here doing all the switching and he is
uh my my new
I wouldn't even call him a protege he's
just kind of this like alcoholic that
I'm trying to okay
he's living in my guest room he moved
here
to Austin a couple months ago and
um I have the studio upstairs
and I need somebody to help me with
video switching so he's the guy doing it
but then he has this like crippling
alcohol addiction that turns him into a
different person really from Kyle to
Carl and he's just useless and I hate
him and I almost beat his ass the last
time he got drunk and then now he's
sober
and now he's the most fun person ever to
be around and he's learning all this
kind of stuff he's learned from all the
alcoholism yeah to be a person if he
ever
I'm gonna kick him out of my house I am
dead serious
um also I don't know if you uh notice
the way that the wide shot looks but
this is the wide shot that Kyle set up
it is crooked
see this is this is all the alcohol has
damaged your brain so badly you don't
even know what's straight anymore so let
me just give you a piece of advice Kyle
don't go to the wide shot just keep it
switching back and forth well at least I
get a good sense of what it looks like
have you gotten a good sense of Kyle's
alcoholism it was bad dude oh really bad
yeah I uh what is uh do you care if we
talk about this
do do what you gotta do okay well you're
not miked so maybe you should be quiet
do you want to be miked
no let's we don't want a mic I hope they
can hear him well that's funny like
alcoholism and like just funny that like
your weakness can be abstained from like
some people are shitty people and that's
just a part of them but like for him
it's just like it comes out during
specific times so you can just avoid
that specific thing yeah and I've really
reinforced
to Kyle that he's not a bad person and
that people like being around him when
he's sober or even when he smokes pot
but like literally everybody that knows
him the minute he drinks they're like
dude get away from me because he's a
horrible person he's the worst drug I've
ever met in my life so why would you
what do you think you're going back to
the alcohol if if everyone doesn't like
it you know I don't know no good I don't
know but he doesn't have a blank so
really I bet he's like so self-conscious
and always self-critical and always
thinking about himself like in a
negative way and then when he drinks
he's not thinking about himself at all
and it's like oh maybe you should be you
should maybe you should hate yourself a
little bit normally I would say that
that makes sense but there's no reason
for Kyle to be very extremely critic
self-critical or self-conscious because
he's a pretty good person he's pretty
smart but then when he drinks it's it's
just dude alcoholism in general is a
um a very heinous disease you know uh we
had Chris Rogers on lasers podcast and
we talked to him about that
and uh dude he had a guy
he got into like so much trouble when he
used to drink like someone shot a gun
dude somebody he he was in a car with
somebody
and the guy was on meth I don't know if
he knew this at the time but I was on
math he wrote on his window and just
started firing a gun out of a window at
somebody and then sped off into the
night and took Chris on this wild
[__] goose in the middle of a trailer
put a gun to his head and said if you
ever tell anybody about this and and
then Chris said two days later he moved
to Austin yeah that's
and he still didn't quit drinking after
that even if he got himself into that
situation that was his fault yeah but if
he wouldn't have been drinking that kind
of people exactly because some people
when they drink they just get themselves
into that kind of situation and I'm kind
of like that too yeah but uh the good
news is that the older I've gotten
I'm good at um
avoiding situations like that generally
I had a situation the other day
dude did I tell you I had a heart attack
no yeah
yeah I mean it wasn't the other day it
was like three months ago so oh [__] it
was right after Adam hartle died okay
yeah that's scary yeah I had like a mild
heart it's like contagious heart attacks
it's something in the air dude
I don't know man I got it well uh yeah
but I guess um I I got that happened and
I got sober for a while and then I
realized that
um
I can control my drinking for the most
part uh
uh as long as I don't do drugs you know
what I mean okay so you just drink
just drink beer I don't drink liquor at
all none that's specific yeah are you
gonna do this not that yeah well I don't
drink a lot yeah you don't really do I
didn't think that yeah I do a lot of uh
psychedelics mostly I've been doing a
lot of shrooms recently but mostly weed
I like not being myself I like having an
objective be like Oh I'm always sober
how about I just put on another skin I
don't want to always be doing things one
way I'd rather like have a different way
my brain can be
I like changing my brain
yeah that's a good way to Garner Insight
empathy and perspective yeah to yourself
to others right because you're like oh
if this person is going through this
trip yeah like everything's a trip like
oh this guy's tripping because his mom
died or he's tripping because he just
went on stage so it's like oh everyone's
in a different mind State and what would
I like when I'm tripping would I like
someone being like dude are you tripping
right now what drugs are you on and be
like oh you're high okay whatever I
don't need a learner
listen to you or you know like empathize
with you it's like hey maybe just
because he's high doesn't mean he's like
an idiot or like I shouldn't listen to
him but like this is just how he happens
to be but everyone is something like
sobriety isn't the default or the best
way to be
for some people it is Kyle
yeah uh have you ever tried ketamine
yeah what do you think about that nose
drugs I don't really get high from it's
you don't it doesn't have to be a nose
drug
although I'm not really good at that I
guess I shouldn't be promoting injecting
it but uh yeah for a sober guy you're
really excited about injecting ketamines
listen dude
relax but I'm just saying it uh
um it can be used clinically it has some
clinical purpose
and um
that is a drug that can kind of reframe
your brain too uh like specifically for
depression you know how LSD has been
used for
um helping get people off of alcohol and
cigarettes and stuff like that ketamine
has been used a lot for things like PTSD
and depression yes and and anxiety but
that's one of those drugs that it's such
a dissociative and it takes you so far
out of your body that it really can give
you like a completely different frame of
reference
on whatever you're experiencing yeah or
whatever feelings you're experiencing
also I will say that
it's one of those things that uh it can
be easily abused and if you do abuse it
it pretty much loses all meaning
and I think drugs in general are kind of
like that I think a lot of times if you
if you do too many of too much of
something it completely becomes devoid
of meaning yeah you know yeah if you do
it too much don't you think like a lot
of drug addiction is like trauma that
you're diagnosing with drugs
trauma that you're trying to like self
self uh medicate medicate yeah I guess
you can look at it that way I mean I
didn't start doing drugs because I was
traumatized or anything though I started
doing drugs in high school when I was a
teenager because I just was curious and
hung out with really shitty kids like
other kids I hung out with all the
hoodlum kids I mean there's no trauma in
your life that you're trying to medicate
in high school
why were you attracted to bad people I
mean yeah there probably is but I don't
think it was anything that was
really
they're probably who touched you yeah
well now
me
I think like uh you know it's sad that a
lot of people are suffering uh and then
drugs on top of that could be dangerous
but I think it's fun to do drugs in the
right settings right right moderation
your head is so fragile and if you're
like going through a bad life and then
you do drugs on top of that then it can
make it worse so maybe like the drug
gets a bad rap
yeah like like
meth yeah it's kind of like that yeah
everyone has an idea of what meth is
well maybe not in meth but amphetamines
in general yeah like Adderall
what do you think about whippets those
are horrible I did like it's probably
600 whippets one night and in in uh in
back in SB
uh Barbara yeah we went to college out
there um I did like this dude it was
[__] or the Santa Cruz
I mean
Vaqueros Gauchos something like that
uh yeah I mean that's horrible because
whippets are like killing brain cells oh
yeah it makes your head hurt yeah no
they're they're [__] terrible I hate
them if you had to associate it with a
food what food would uh whippets be
whipped cream
the obvious and easy low-hanging part of
an answer so it's just like eating a
bunch of whipped cream yeah it's like
dude the whippets are so terrible and
you can buy them in a store
the drug the drug
prohibition doesn't make any sense on a
number of levels you know they use you
know you know who created a heroine the
bear aspirin company oh yeah and they
created it as a drug to get people off
of [__] um
morphine after the Civil War and they
used to sell it in a vial with a needle
attached to it and and it was they and
then they realized that it was more
addictive than morphine and then they
really started pumping it out and then
it just became a whole [__] thing and
then of course they create another drug
to get you off of heroin Suboxone and
then they it's just it's a [__] cycle
dude it's yeah I probably by Design or
it's we're just watching a lot of
unfortunate
um coincidences that they keep creating
drugs that are [__] more this will
help this yeah
it's like in Australia they like got
rabbits to fight off the whatevers and
the rabbits got out of control so they
brought in the foxes that bread out of
control so it's like we're always trying
to fix it with something else yeah and
yeah I mean I don't know man I feel like
didn't [__] Portland just legalize
drugs everything yeah oh that wasn't
recent but recently a year or two ago
how is Portland exploded right now it
was already a [__]
they posted like the most dangerous
crime ridden cities and every because
I'm subscribed to a bunch of City
subreddits yeah and every city somewhere
is like oh thank God we didn't make top
15. the Portland is one of those cities
they're like thank God we aren't
everyone makes the sound so bad do you
know where Singapore is yeah and you
know southeast Asia very conservative
very they have Corporal like a
city-state it's like a colony of China
yeah in the middle of the drugs are
completely illegal you can't smoke you
can't spit on the street [__] chew
gum you can't do anything an interesting
social experience it's a very wealthy
good place to live yeah it's like a
gated community it's right Beverly Hills
so an interesting experiment would be
too
legalize all drugs there just flood the
[__] place with [__] nerds and
just see those soon on aspirin I mean if
it if if the place got worse then that's
a pretty empirical that's empirical
evidence that drugs are it's also not
the best setting because that's like
from going from zero to a hundred like
you gotta ramp it up well hey
you say potato I say potato you wanna
you like that you like virgins you like
[__] virgins what like drug virgins
you just want like someone to do drugs
and just get [__] out of their head
because if you're like 50 years old and
you lived a whole life in the same brain
and then you change that brain suddenly
that there's like wires getting crossed
and if you're young and you're like
electricity is then you just destroy
your brain chemistry right off the bat
yeah yeah that's what happened to me
dude I got prescribed Adderall when I
was 15. and I took it for a [__] how
old am I 30. well I'm taking it for 50.
that's [__] years that's like our
society like we don't know what human
beings are like we just treat them like
objects so like if we like exploit
people like we treat each other you know
women are it's like it's gonna the
poison is in us we are we just have a
false view of humanity and we [__] each
other I think a lot of people like to be
in worldified what do you think about
that
I think that we create a society where
people like to be objectified where it's
like hey I guess I'm an object now treat
me decently yeah because there's no
value to being a human so at least I
could be like a nice Porsche or
something
treat me like if you were a car what
would you mean
if I was a car right now I'd probably be
like a Ford or a BMW or like a hybrid
a Ford Aura beam those aren't even the
same I don't know I like BMWs I don't
know I just feel like pretty middle of
the road average
trying to keep my head low I don't think
you're a middle of the road kind of guy
though I think you're uh
funny
genius Asian
I feel like I'm morose and depressed
morose yeah this is this is gonna be one
of the first podcast I I
listen man is that racist or sorry
um no it's not you're you're you have a
expansive vocabulary what what does that
mean everything's like sad like Mortuary
or like death morbid like morbid yeah
okay I mean I I kind of picked up that
picked up on that but um that's how I
feel I come off to people like I'm just
like depressed and I like depress people
and I don't know why is that you're like
that really thank you yeah that's been
an insecurity of mine
really yeah like I don't want to drone
on and be boring and like low monotone
voice like the world is falling apart
you have like a pragmatic inter
intellectual
perspective on things and that's
like that's different than what a lot of
comics like you know that the
documentary that we're working on yeah
that was one of the reasons why I really
wanted you in it was because you have a
different take as opposed to a lot of
comics and just people in general I
don't know really why I use Comics to
pigeonhole that but Whites Whites a lot
of what
um
or I don't know what it is because I
grew up with white people so I've not
really grown up with Asian people and my
parents obviously indoctrinated me into
the Asian way of thinking so maybe a
little bit of that mixed with whiteness
and then this is what you get but I
don't know it's like how much of it can
you change how much of it should I
change it's like this is how I see the
world well I don't see anything wrong
with it yeah thank you okay yeah because
like I feel like a lot of Americans
sometimes are uh happier and like they
put a premium on feeling good and I'm
like I don't have to feel good I just
need the truth and what what's going on
so but I try to that lends itself to
having those depressive thoughts yeah
because and Happiness by the way is a
fleeting feeling it doesn't really exist
and it definitely is not maintained over
there's no longevity to happiness yeah
unless you're a [__] idiot and you're
chasing butterflies right or you are one
of those people that truly puts in their
brain
um
they you quantify your happiness through
objects and validation through Instagram
and buying a [__] car or whatever
that there are people like that that are
happy but they're [__] idiots and no
I don't have your own people like that
that's personally it's a signal it's
like oh let's just Chase having the
light turn green on the nuclear reactor
it's like no you shouldn't just make
sure the light is green you should make
sure like the reason why the light is
green is going properly like you can't
just be like I want happiness happiness
is what you get as a byproduct of doing
something right or well achieving a goal
or success well you know that's when you
set a goal and accomplish it you there's
a serotonin release in your brain you
know that's something that you want to
that you should want to do not only to
better yourself and and get more out of
life in terms of fulfillment and
experience but also because it will make
you happy and most people get it through
family or a group and we don't have that
so we're like starved of like love and
happiness and then we're like oh this
drug will give me a close approximation
of the serotonin I get from watching my
child grow up right right we're like
having to self-diagnose and getting it
and not in the healthy ways because if
you get it through a child growing up
your brain has like mechanisms to like
[__] make sure you don't overdose on
it or like become unrealistic or like
yeah well crazy
that's yeah I mean I obviously have well
you know but I mean no nobody watching
this would know this but I have my
situation with my kid and I I can't
spend any time with my son so there's
definitely I'm I'm definitely missing a
massive piece of my life that I just
used to fill fill that void with you
know
strippers and and drinking
yeah
but that is very it's their but they're
vacuous and I don't just mean vacuous
like empty headed I mean they're like
they're such a vacuum that they suck the
joy out of your own [__] life you
mean anything that you're trying to fill
your life with including strippers and
drugs and
specifically strippers specifically or
just loose women are very dangerous I
think and and that goes for women that
are going out and hooking up with with
playboys and [__] too I'm not or women
I'm not totally one-sided but my point
is that people yeah people like it yeah
if you if you fill your life with that
you're you you're setting yourself up
for failure in your love life regardless
yeah unless you're just not looking for
that at all which people are so powerful
you can either make something greater
than the sum of its parts together or
the opposite worse than all your misery
yeah dude yeah because they're they're
smart they're adjusting they're like
figuring you out and then you're doing
the same and then you just get into the
spiral of like negativity it's not a
stable right the best thing you can do
if you do have darkness in your life or
you feel empty or if you're in the void
if you know what I mean by that the void
um you can uh you just need to literally
focus on yourself and being the best
person the best version of yourself that
you can be and you know I mean I don't
know man I'm not I don't like believing
like uh you know like uh the abrahamic
god or the Hindu god or anything like
that but I do believe that there's a
higher power and I do think that
karmically or energy or whatever it is
that the Universe puts out if you do
focus on yourself good [__] will happen
and if you set goals and try to manifest
stuff it like you're even even if it's
something simple yeah you're way more
likely to accomplish at least a level of
feeling content or or some fulfillment
then if you just keep going down that
rabbit hole over and over and looping
it's it's sick it could become cyclical
you're just chasing like the dragon yeah
getting rid of the negative feelings
instead of creating positive feelings
handling them yeah well yeah I think
like uh if you're constantly working on
yourself it's better but then a lot of
people are like why should I work on
myself who am I to be an amazing person
but then if you're like oh there's a
higher power there's a higher cause and
it's like oh I'm not making myself
better for my own selfish desire because
I have ego and I want to be a great
person I'm doing it because of this
reason God or Society or like the people
around me are my family so I think
people need to have a higher reason to
become a better person
because otherwise it's just selfish and
I think people have a natural aversion
to selfishness which can be
self-defeating because like if you're a
better person you're going to be better
for everyone in your life and that's
going to make everyone's life better
so I think like something that's a very
Eastern way of thinking yeah like right
Collective yeah which is why countries
like Japan are so
they're pretty cohesive clean like
efficient yeah yeah I mean I'm I'm
personally
I'm of the thought process that I
legitimately think Japan might be the
greatest country on Earth serious I'm
dead serious yeah a lot of white people
love Japan why is that because they're
like they're doing what we're doing but
better way better they're but they're
doing but America's great too I mean the
inventions and the art
um I definitely
um I definitely love America I love
Texas dude I've lived in a lot of
not a lot I've lived in a handful of
different states I've lived in Ohio
Kentucky Tennessee I spent some time
spent a lot of time in New York with my
grandparents out there and then uh I
spent a summer in Chicago I lived in
California North and South uh that's not
everywhere I don't have a massive uh
you know frame of reference but
comparatively to everywhere else I've
lived Texas is the [__] dude yeah it's
the it is my favorite state by far I
think the people here are the best yeah
I think there's something about Texas
where it's like the people are free to
be themselves yeah I think uh yeah
people here are trying to be the best
like in Asia it's great that everyone's
thinking about you know how to keep the
subway station clean but I think uh it's
good to be like how do I be the best
version of myself how do I excel as an
individual because if you're only
thinking about the collective then
you're not thinking about the most
important part of the collective that
you can actually change like you can't
change a lot of parts of the collective
for me that's a good point but if
everyone's working on themselves and
making themselves better I think it
makes the collective better it's just a
balance and I don't think it should be
divided between eastern and western
because then it's like oh I can't do it
I'm Eastern or I think it's just like
how people like a like a truism of life
it's like some people
uh some sometimes you think about the
collective sometimes you should think
about the individual and you should do
both to make your life better
overall which is going to make the
collective better it's not like either
or
it's like one and the same
you digesting that
um I think the guys the other guys here
yeah thank you do you want to do the
wide shot
yeah yeah switching to the Crooked ass
watch I think you set up Kyle thanks
you're [__] fired dude
I wonder what it looks like you're hired
you're fired you're hired you're fired
um I'm sweating I can actually pull it
up on my phone right now it's like on
like 20 second delay
yeah just make it a little straighter
and also our heads
should be on all right now yeah there
you go that's a little bit better now
make it straight though Kyle
like you see how Hans is like a foot
above me
use the table as a um
yeah the back of the table is like the
Horizon yeah use the you
Gary needs to be higher
Kyle
use this this should be completely
straight
so uh what do you think you think we
should turn the fan on
is it hot in here yeah do the mics pick
up the fan a little bit Carl that's not
even
like that
are we gonna have the other dudes come
in and sit in on this yeah oh okay well
uh try try
um maybe zooming out the the lens there
Kyle
that looks better
yeah it's getting there too it's getting
there I want to cut both
do you want us to do that live or do you
just want to wrap this one up
how long have we been recording
uh
almost a half an hour yeah I mean that's
fine dude we can we can cut mine out and
be good to go I don't care it's fine
we can just figure it out
what do you think about somebody said go
see your son dude bro
yeah dude that's not really how that
works yeah it'd be great if I could go
see my son I would go see him every day
these comments man
[Music]
somebody else said speaking of
alcoholism I'm gonna pour one up
pour one out for homies for alcoholic
homies
yeah
um
is it hot in here is it just Hans
you know I'm not gonna lie dude Kyle
didn't do it too bad of a job making the
the camera straight
don't tell him that no you can't dude I
gotta let him uh he needs to learn
there's a chair
Kyle what's up
let's see we're alive who is that who
are these people in here who's Maddie
what's up dude watch out for those
chords and you gotta watch out the for
the chords come stay here uh you can
grab that chair and go sit over here
watch out for those chords though don't
open that door there's a hey if you're
going under uh you might have to crawl
under the table between the there's a
chair downstairs if you could get a
chair
not you Dane
why don't you guys saw that the hit mode
bit right there
um do we need to unmute his mic yeah
passenger yeah
so what do you think about the the
Silicon Valley Bank going under
yes awesome but you can explain that one
no I have a good value banquet under it
I read something about a banking uh
China just went on awesome remarks
really I'm Going Under
going under the table I mean
obstacle course at least all right hey
uh Kyle we might need you to adjust
those levels on those mics
because we have now two more people
on this is the same lion hello holy [__]
yeah you definitely need to turn
here
should we turn the fan on and also we
need to zoom out on that camera uh that
one that one is um
though I don't know if Kyle's
sophisticated enough to focus
yeah twist it one way and then Kyle can
tell us you got it on the wide right now
Kyle
okay
um yeah let's just do a uh let's sing
with it until Kyle's right yeah and so
what do you think about the Jews
I mean look man not a fan
oh I actually love it
not a Jew but big Jew guy yeah what do
you like about that Dynasty uh yeah pull
the mic down like this
morning towards yourself well it's not
gonna there you go it's doing fine is
that uh is that an omni Direction what's
the term for that it's um Holly
he I don't know if this is an
omnidirectional or if it's just a
regular uh like a cone why are you so
that why is he putting yours so down
uh just for I like for like volume wise
yeah that's oh that sounds better that's
this we don't need it all right thank
you there we go no no that's the game
for the mics don't worry about the
headphones the headphones
no no get talk hello sounds good right
yeah that sounds good that's good and
then you turn me back up though I can't
hear it all now actually thanks now you
you'd be talking to yours yeah perfect
one two three definitely it has to be
higher
can use the diaphragm a little more
how's that why does it sound so quiet on
his I don't know this side is quiet am I
not talking I can remember talking loud
huh that's fine can we get the camera
now
um make sure that uh if you twist it
like is that Mike three is it catching
part four Hans I don't know
you might he might have hit the wrong
ones well can we get can we get the
camera now
let's do the camera thing
we would twist it and like see if it
zooms out already are you looking at it
so like when I'm twisting you actually
see it louder good all right it's fine
we're not worrying about the sound right
now all right am I twisted what do you
think about the basketball league that
uh we're all a part of the basketball
that we're all a part of oh is there an
American I know there's are you talking
about like the client is it catching
both of us
yeah all right which way this way
because it brings people together but I
don't like it because
certain people like act like we should
all listen to them but I challenge their
Authority oh is this a shut up and
dribble situation yeah is that you're
getting that because I agree I do agree
to shoot the ball I don't care about
your politics there's too much politics
in the basketball yeah like LeBron James
uh
I see it more on like the news and I see
them in a Lakers uniform shooting the
ball I feel like I just see him talking
about reading he does the book thing you
know well I think that's because you
guys actually appreciate Sports I don't
appreciate Sports I'm more entertained
with what do you what else are you
thinking what's going on you're more
like a theater nerd yeah I don't care I
don't I don't know what teams are
playing but if somebody does something
weird or says something crazy that's the
only thing I'm able to contribute in the
conversation so it's great
like let's say zoom out of will because
it's all right unless you want to scoot
over yeah and can you get the curtains
because I don't want anyone to see
what's actually going on
yeah the walls my bare walls but yeah I
mean I think uh Lebron James it's like
is it him or is it like the people that
pay attention to him that want to like
either be supporting him or enraged by
him it's a good point like Steven
there's people whose careers are just
based off the even a Smith is so
negative except yeah he's always got a
scowl on his face his face looks
physically like his personality it's the
thing I don't know if it's is he trying
to be funny because I laugh at a lot of
the things he's saying probably I don't
know if he is well I mean
the guy is negative though he's always
just I mean yeah it's like a bunch of
jocks are just like doing crazy [__] and
then this nerd is in a suit like in a
fancy Studio like you did that wrong do
you figure that those are the wannabe
job those are the guys that wanted to be
the quarterback oh yeah yeah they're
like they're like definitely people that
need a mech suit I mean somebody's got
these guys are great at what they do and
then what we're attracted to is like hey
what can't you do right let's start
quizzing them on these things let's see
where they can like where we can like
mess him up and interview him it's kind
of weird but I think but it's for people
like me who have no idea how the games
play the best joke would be someone who
has a body of LeBron but the mind of
Stephen A Smith I think there is some
value to like the critical way of
thinking absolutely yeah I mean the
brain knowledge is power but uh is there
do you have an example of that who's
who's this stud which is the quick
thinker who's just like an idiot
like Stephen A Smith just like a snide
little [__] I feel like
I feel like if you're a jock you get
humbled enough where you're like oh I
can't just like be completely negative
but if you're a nerd then it's like
easier to do that yeah it's more of a
pessimistic Outlook I think the smarter
you get right isn't that a thing like
Geniuses are sad yeah I think physical
shame does something to people you get
that curtain
oh yeah
okay there we go this is good it's
getting hurt in that way yeah thank you
um yeah
yeah probably but hey you know what
that's baseball can you get that curtain
and that's uh that's a sports joke yeah
that's a did that did I uh stand did I
hit that one out of the park another
Sports joke yeah all right I'll stop
trying to be funny I'm gonna kill myself
okay that way yeah by the way real
recognize real in the mustache that's
good notice dude the first thing I
noticed was your most of it how long
you've been running I think we got the
same shape same form dude you know what
I have been on and off with the stash
for probably a year and a half I feel
you every once in a while I have a
mental breakdown and I shave it I was
gonna say it's an attitude thing and
then you know what happens I realize
that I look like I'm 22 without it yeah
and I don't get laid as much not even in
these parts and then I grow back okay
yeah I wish I could grow a stash I'm
pretty jealous I'm just I'm aiming for
Hans stash right there that if I can
just if you can just see it like that
would be amazing I can't even get there
yeah yours is like you just ate a
chicken wings yeah it looks dirty it's
like really hot all right what is with
your Mike you sound so good right now
talk again hello
is this good a little lower why does
mine sound like I'm talking at the
bottom of a well
um maybe it's the stone in the hello
hello
you can pop the headphones on if you
want to hear it Kyle pop those oh he
doesn't have any I'm sorry oh
yeah
oh wow this is different let me know if
it's too pops didn't get out of the zone
out of the cash well we heard it first
and then I was like how's the
conversation dude this is what like
Adderall feels like because when you
phone's on I'm like oh my God there's
the birds not chirping around my my
brain I can crank okay now actually
really five mils no that one needs to be
up
because that's him
am I too loud I think it's good now it's
fine I think it's good now that the
headphones are off I do feel like I've
been talking like a [__] so yeah and
you tap that up a little bit yeah let's
go back
you got your cord wrapped
rap situation I don't want to tug on
that's why that's attached to the camera
dude oh Eagle Eye Gary over there you
got a sharp eye that's what I do for a
living dude you could be a sniper you
must have I mean that's that's with the
mustache too the gun powder so you don't
swallow yeah it looks good you guys look
like men they look like what you would
you know want what I would want to be I
I am a man yeah I'm working on it that's
the thing I'm not and the mustache works
great for that because people say things
how old are you I'm 12 I'm 29 but my
life's falling apart well then that
means guess what you are my friend oh
man stay over 40.
no and it does it does add like 10 years
yeah when you stop being attractive
that's when you're gonna start being a
man like oh you can't give a [__] about
looking good then you have to focus
solely on other ways is that really what
it is yeah like men you can't you can't
be too into how you look okay it's a
good point that's a good point okay see
I'm like I'm at the point where I need
to figure out am I am I gonna be a hat
guy or am I gonna let the hairline go um
because I'm looking at you three fellas
right now you don't have that same
problem
anytime I comb my hair I see like one
strand I'm like oh my God I'm going bald
you just got it you got to use um use
that anti-dht shampoo oh yeah dihydro
testosterone is what makes your hair
fall out if you have a sensitivity in
your scalp so this is uh I want to go
against that did I strike a chord So you
you're in on this ah dude I used to
inject a [__] it's biotine right on a
podcast that's live bio teams are you
eating those apartments yeah I don't
know it's back on track baby I got you
your nails are glowing that's another
thing yeah no I take um I take
multivitamin from uh what's that place
Kyle
Centrum GNC no I used to take that 50
plus
men's do they still have GNC yeah it's
crazy yeah you get the real stuff around
that yeah you get
um real stuff that actually works yeah
you just you see when the guy's off you
could do the Christian [__] or we got
some atheist stuff in the back
see I'm the guy that just buys it I just
go to the I go into the store and I go I
see the guy with ABS on the picture I'm
like that that's what I needed excuse me
machines you just go to the economy be
like let me have that I'll buy that
please yeah the ABS are scam well if
there was a story thank you everything
like the balding store going to the
store you didn't pay enough credits
that's why you're bald you can just
adjust every part of your body oh that
was the case I wouldn't have this much
hair dude I'd be [__] if you want to
wait for it you had like a Fabio hair
it's Fabio's like silky right it just
kind of goes in the wind Majestic
wandissimo yeah that's a deep because
that's a real Fairly Odd Parents how
come only black people look good bald
mostly
and Italian because they have good skin
yeah because see I would just look like
a tomato like a tomato but you know I
wouldn't look good bald it'd be a bad
look it looked like Bill Burr but you
guys that's he kind of he's kind of rock
yeah but he's famous right and he's
funny as [__] that's why he looks good
and then I'm the exactly the exact
opposite sorry
it's not working out but no I mean it's
a good look to Aspire to you're a poor
nobody right yeah you're I could be here
that shampoo I was talking about because
if you go bald you're [__] well I
could be a sit in that like the Grammys
there's I'm just saying there's a route
for me if I'm if to stick on this path
there's a route for me okay yeah you do
got the bill burlik going on yeah yeah
you kind of do people are gonna be like
oh this guy's funny he's genetically
similar to a one of the best should I
read into it you [__] pricks well you
can't you guys in no more Direction You
Gotta Have a whole head of hair or you
gotta if you go too bald then you gotta
just shave it because you guys that hold
on to it too much then it I I saw Ben
Franklin the other day and it was like
he was Ben Franklin you mentioned it you
kind of got a little bit profound father
you don't know if you're Ben or like a
Mexican Ben Franklin or like a young
Leonardo DiCaprio Gilbert Grape when he
went full
no offense well that's what the physical
never do a full grape you don't want to
get a grape charge you know what I'm
saying hey a little more cold crispy boy
for uh you guys want some Bruce
absolutely this is Texas baby
to people Lone Star Budweiser white claw
I know you want white
claws
one white cloth
we have a hard and fast rule that Kyle's
not allowed to drink
is that it's not on the is you have it
on the wide shot yeah it's white if
you're [__] good at this
Lone Star please thank you I was telling
everybody I was telling Hans earlier
that uh Kyle is my protege so to speak
okay but he has a crippling alcohol
problem really yeah he turns into a
different person okay I did notice he
was a little Shaker a person who I have
to threaten with violence
I think he's just like threatening
people with violence I think he's a fine
alcoholic no dude it's bad no I don't
want to I think he's fine I don't want a
mustache stereotype you but when you
you're a belt guy huh
can you believe that he's happy so but
that's that's not just in essence we're
talking that's a color he is Essence
baby magazine he's like a strong spinny
woman he's a quiet but silent but deadly
and also no he's mixed dude I think
honestly I think he's like six percent
black he leans into it we're all heading
that direction with his hair right beige
thank you sir what's up Kyle
uh
beige directions happy belated February
by the way don't you think there's going
to be some people that are appear just
so that we have that stock
yeah sure yeah I mean that's I
I uh yeah yeah give me a butterflies in
please thank you advice
I think it's probably German yeah no it
is I heard that Germans are more
integrated into America because they
came here first and they took all the
land and then the Irish came later and
they had to be policemen on the coast
huddling together no people that the
people that joke yeah well I'm not
arguing I mean English there are
accomplished in Spanish
is too popular I mean we have their
language but I just feel like they were
first first I don't think there were a
bunch I don't think they had the numbers
like the Germans did well Germans did it
create the hamburger which is an
integral part of U.S culture I eat one
every other day that would actually the
hamburger was created in uh Hamburg
Germany hold on I don't know if that's
true I I think it was I think it's uh
uh New Haven Connecticut lose so any
reason should I look that up if you did
like a [__] 23 crazy it's literally
called a hamburger well I'm out of your
mind that might be the inspiration
behind the name I'm not saying that you
know I want to keep Kyle focused on the
cameras if we did the 23andMe of all
Americans what do you think the
percentage what do you think the highest
percentage would be German or English
um English well I think so no Germans I
thought were second because the English
came over first right yeah I mean they
set up the culture but I don't think
that they had the genetics numbers no
the first hamburger most people are
German yeah that's true yeah dude it
goes back to Hamburg Germany I am yeah
okay so lose lunch is a scam New Haven
Connecticut well there's also something
about this conference well because I
read the menu they got a whole bio dude
the first hamburger goes back to 1747.
okay this place they gotta stick up they
won't even let you use ketchup Oh I
thought you just had a hamburger there
and you're like you know who probably
made it that sounds like a tourist trap
it's too listen to it get this well you
can't use ketchup and then people are
like oh okay because it's original or
some [__] two pieces of white toast
no cheese just the Patty doesn't happen
yeah that's really bad no you go there
for the novelty apparently there's also
some [__] it does sound like the
first to something which is first is
never the best maybe the first in
America but I mean it's literally called
a hamburger yeah
I think Kanye's the first black Nazi
that doesn't mean it's a good thing no
not true yeah I was gonna say as soon as
I said it that didn't feel right the
Nazis the Nazis units that is a fact
wow and Arab SS units look at that black
people they were trying to spread I mean
well they're going livestock like
they're such victims but turns out they
were Nazis it goes full circle it really
does so you just dig deeping up into
history and everyone's been a victim
yeah but
that's not a hill I'm gonna die on
she probably didn't add to that well and
also I mean history is created by the
winners that is true so it's written by
the way we write the Books you guys
should have done so good job writing it
because you guys are like really like
down on yourselves one of the most
American guys I know thanks you bleed
red white and blue well yeah I do but
it's like funny like you wrote the
history and then you forgot to leave out
the genocide and the slavery you like
kept that in there it's like I thought
winners write the history well you
probably didn't do a better job well
yeah I also didn't write any of that
[__]
I'm not really white
Japan is really bad you can't just do
that now Warcraft dude you can do
whatever you want yeah you can always
have done whatever you want that's the
thing people don't realize it takes a
[__] black Nazi to open everybody's
eyes I'm not and again that's not a hill
I'm gonna die on either no I'm not gonna
die on Hamburger Hill no I'm not gonna
go down with that Kanye West Nazi ship
no I'll take a nap but I will say that
it that uh recently people saying crazy
[__] and just you know that kind of
atmosphere means you can just do
whatever you want there's no Rhyme or
Reason to anything anymore
it didn't happen before him I'm just
saying like do you remember Rachel Dolce
I'm like I'm halfway serious about this
but you know what I'm talking about I
don't know the girls always talk like
you have a point
I do do that I don't know why dolezal
sometimes they do sometimes you don't
sometimes you do sometimes you don't
sometimes I can go [__] myself but the
Rachel Dolce was the white chick who
said that she was black yeah and got
like she pulled the Kyle
the Elizabeth Warren he's more you're
more convincing than her I was never
well yeah but he's actually like part
black Rachel Dolce was completely white
and she like permed her hair and tanned
her skin and like did all this stuff and
then got to position it like the NAACP
chapter in her town and all this other
crazy [__] and then it turned out like
yo she's completely full of [__] if she
did that in the era of filter she
probably could have got away with it a
little more you know well she did this
like 10 years ago that's what I'm saying
maybe not even I feel like today is Eric
he pulled off blackface yeah yeah yeah
well no because she's still she yeah
she's busted now yeah busted well now
she's like the leader of the biracial so
now she's the leader of Kanye West's uh
black Nazi movement I don't know what
she's doing now well that sucks about
America is like the certain parts of the
culture is cut off racially like you can
only do the rap thing if you're black
but in Korea everyone's Korean so if you
want to be like the cool Korean you can
be cool in Korean but in America if you
want to like talk in Ebonics and you're
white it's just you can't yeah those
those countries like Korea and Japan
have uh very high levels of racial
heteronomy is that the word for that no
but we're going with it yeah I mean
that's not always good that's pretty
much everything yeah I mean it's like
Japan is like 99 Japanese Germany is not
super German though it's right but
compared to America it's like 70 okay 80
60 what percent German do you think
Germany is
oh I would say over under yeah young
young 70s late 60s I would say 70s yeah
I have no idea well neither do we to
your point though I spent a little time
in Japan dude I stuck out like a sore
thumb couldn't buy clothes out there
really like Tower I'm like a huge guy
out there
they don't have like clothes for big
Japanese people they don't exist dude a
big Japanese person is like your turn
you know Japanese have grain gained like
five inches in height over the last 50
years I think I think that is really
yeah what is that from better diet
I thought they're not known for having
like really good diet though eating rice
I think it's just like survival the
fittest with Godzilla
they just saw Americans and they were
like oh [__] let's start growing now
yeah we want to play basketball no but I
thought they had like some of the best
diet like for longevity I don't think
for like premium sport performance they
had like good like long-term price is
good but it's not there's not a lot of
nutrients in it yeah okay interesting uh
I'm a wrestlers eat a lot of it but
Germany is 86 German that's pretty
German that's pretty German every
country is like that except for like
turkey I know there's like a lot of
different people that invaded that place
so they have like a mix of different
types of people like a lot of like um
racial homogeny homogeneity if I'm
telling you I think that's a word no if
that's not it you're in the ballpark I
know you are not a hill I'm gonna die
um you know Argentina is the whitest
country in the world
fact nice and uh you know that's right
okay dude yeah
that's that actually is legitimately
part of it um that's not like made up
yeah it's horrible it's well it's insane
because
well it's yeah not the hell I want to go
on Tim Kennedy went on that Hill dude I
don't think Hitler he has a whole show
he went down to Argentina and he was
like finally he was like finding
artifacts and like old like pictures
like a little German Town in Argentina
that's like a bunch of them it's called
Argentina
no he's right yeah it's all like that
yeah it's wild
it's like in uh Leavenworth in
Washington there's a little German
Village there's a little German Village
here to the west of Austin New Braunfels
isn't I thought I said this early but
isn't barbecue like German too yeah okay
is that true Barbara I thought polka's
uh polish uh polka that makes sense
same part of the world I can only I'm
only looking up these two I think they
beg to differ from them I don't think
Polish people want to be especially with
Germans there are a lot of weird little
German colonies like like new Brooklyn
talking about New Braunfels I guess so
okay polka music came from Bohemia an
area within the Czech Republic and what
was I think barbecue is BBQ German I
thought of for sure Australian
that's shrimp American barbecue has
roots in Germany but I don't think all
barbecue goes back to Germany roasting
food on fire is German I think that's I
think that's caveman yeah I was gonna
say
well barbecue has to do with the sauce
and all that stuff too that's what I
associated with it's kind of hard to
clean though like I cooked food that's
my culture it's kind of insane what's
the style it's the style of cooking it
like uh like fried food goes back to the
Irish
um like the poor Irish in America
yeah okay
let's get the Irish press and an example
of
um somebody claiming a type of food the
way they cook it that is that is a that
is like a fact that's they were the
first people to do that I believe well
like for instance like Irish they're
known for like potatoes but everybody
has potatoes you guys were just known
for only having potatoes and so that's
like no guys are getting paid since the
same time
looking at the Irish guy yeah no we're
[__] uh we've never done but dude
that's that's like like Native American
people are have arrowheads but everybody
can have an arrowhead but it's clearly
from Native Americans just like potatoes
clearly are an Irish thing originally
that's all right I think they were known
for the Potato Famine where they you
know they couldn't even grow potatoes
yeah
it's ironic it is ironic it's all very
ironic something you're known for you
can't do it yeah actually like
theoretically known for not having
potatoes but well I guess when we got it
together we just have a great we got a
good salt potato now it's something to
talk about home about yeah
it was like mostly a genocide by the
British they were like [__] you work
harder it's like pull yourself up by
your bootstraps kind of thing they could
have helped them but they were like nah
they were like that sounds like
something the British would do yeah they
practice colonization in Ireland they
had plantations in Ireland and then when
capitalism came around they were like
perfectly suited to colonize the world
right like we've practiced on the Irish
wow well and that's what I was going to
say that uh the Irish Irish like
indentured servants and slaves created
fried
food the french fries I'm dead I'm being
dead serious it's so I don't know it it
should be called The Irish fry yeah dude
you know what that's a really good point
yeah
I'm dying on that hill tonight I'm gonna
die from Irish fry Hill yeah
Hamburger Hill you got a little German
in you huh no no no not even a little
one's claim he's 103 Grand dude
is it Hans is an Irish name right no
that's terrible German oh that's what I
meant German yeah
yeah and Irish people are also known for
not handling their alcohol very well
dude I'll have this yeah I'm out dude
Kyle you must be mixed with Irish
because you have crippling alcoholism
it's the worst I've ever seen in my life
yeah well that makes sense we just pour
livers is what it is yeah
dude you're not Mike man
potatoes from South America
yeah dude okay okay
yeah and and pineapples are from [__]
Antarctica dude what are you talking
about well I don't know Irish people are
known
for potatoes
for the lack of I guess what somebody's
doing online it's not true somebody just
doesn't know it for but you guys Stolen
Valor dude I've never been to Ireland
you guys are coming at me so hard I've
not I've got nothings
stolen Valley for the potatoes because I
I mean everyone has potatoes every
culture has potatoes in their food and
you guys are like we can't cook them and
we're known for them
I don't think we are though Grill them I
mean sorry like my uh okay all the rest
we need the stews and stuff it's all
like potato or like it's like just
cabbage and carrots it's not it's poor
people food yeah you know what now that
I think of it I guess Irish people are
just not for being [__] we should
like [__] hot what's your favorite
Irish dish that's stupid yes
I love going to get some Irish stew at
the local pub
make it extra Irish for me you didn't
have a green beer the other half a bowl
do you go you guys party do you guys do
anything for Saint Patrick this isn't a
big Saint Patrick people are known for
beer how do we not line that up already
whiskey too yeah Irish whiskey yeah like
Jameson for example I don't drink
because anytime I drink that [__] I turn
into an [__] Irish piece of [__] yes
I'm smart Irish just certain alcohols
actually change people or some people
just [__] and they're like when I
drink tequila
that's real like I don't know if I don't
buy that if you drink alcohol I'm just
for sure well
sativa and indica it's a hundred percent
he was the only one people can tell the
only alcohol is an upper dude yeah also
I've read that yeah before as well is
that actually yeah how much are they
leaning into it though if we're gonna
fact check that I want to factor out all
the Irish facts
but no I I I've I have heard that
multiple times I have no idea if it's
true I've been doing tequila before like
before it doesn't matter you lost the
boat Kyle stop shaking no it's Brave
only asking Kyle to do research when the
camera's on you so he's forgetting to
switch to us
oh really
great oh [__] you're doing good dude
that's cool whiskey is the definitely
the alcohol that I've heard the most
people say that they can't handle it
because they turn into an [__]
that'll make you hit your kid yeah and I
I mean do you think people that just
drink whiskey probably just have a
problem no there's plenty of people who
drink whiskey that that are fine which
came first like picking her the egg are
people that are attracted to Whiskey bad
people or is the whiskey making them
into bed Whiskey's making them a bad
person we're sure I'm a good guy who's
just who's known for drinking whiskey no
one they just drink whiskey and they're
a bad guy okay wait what
that's what we're saying that's the
chicken of the egg oh okay uh there's
plenty of people who can drink whiskey
and you're a good person yeah okay so
it's the egg but there's also there's
also a lot of people who just can't
handle whiskey like I can drink Vodka
all day and be fine I drink whiskey and
I'm like fist fighting [__] parking
cones and [__] it's crazy I didn't know
that was an actual thing for sure dude
for sure and liquor specifically like a
lot of people just can't drink liquor at
all I don't drink liquor I only drink
beer and I'm fine I can drink like 30
beers and I'm fine to drive
well
in this city yeah in the state of Texas
[__] yeah dude no you know they don't
I'm not being serious though I can I'm
not about the driving part okay
I drink a little bit of liquor and I
will black out dude I literally don't
drink liquor specifically whiskeys
notice that in Austin you can drive
drunk and nothing happens don't pull you
over it's insane and you know why it's
because they got defunded and then
everybody made fun of them and they
don't get the fun they just are like
quiet quitting they're like doing a a
working protest
you know they were defunding a union
walk okay so they were defunded like
five years ago I'm gonna be the odd
manner I don't I don't drink and drive
am I missing out is that [__] no I don't
drink and drive you're here it's
terrible okay so literally the worst
thing you can do other than
ugh other things but but no it's the
worst thing you can do with alcohol
other than like play with guns all right
I mean I need a gun to go to the Vulcan
it's like a car is like it's not like
because it's the worst thing it's
because like we need to do it and then
it's like also dangerous like if I had
to use a gun every time I wanted to like
get food like stick your gun in then
there'd probably be a lot of shootings
when I'm drunk
so you you're saying you have like you
lose self-control when you do I say we
need better public transit okay and then
there'll be way less drunk driving
that's a hill I'm dying on
uh if yo if I'm driving you know the
number one indicator that someone's
going to escape poverty is how close
they are to public transit what that's
true I can see how big yeah yeah because
then you can go to your job reliably and
so those homeless people that sleep on
the bus stop should be they should be
doing very well then I don't know
yeah
oh that was [__] and not true at all
well judging uh counting foreign housed
poor people yeah because you got to
realize there's a shitload of homeless
people and well that's why they're
downtown because that's where everyone
goes that's where everything is right
well not not their jobs because
that's right but that's where they come
up on like a chicken wing I guess I
guess I immediately thought of homeless
people when you said that
the the people yeah when you think of
poverty that's extreme problem so I
guess maybe you probably do have a point
I'm just being a douchebag I mean it's
statistics I know how you get around
statistics you're like what what if it's
not true
what if the numbers are wrong the
numbers
well you know uh you know who you know
who taught me that was Bill Gates
he taught you to he wrote a book called
or or he didn't write it for economic he
had a book in his hand during an
interview called how to lie with
Statistics oh yeah you just dropped
numbers
I mean what are you dude look you know
I'm Not Gonna Keep Me In oh how you lie
with Statistics you have billions of
dollars yeah and you pay people to make
[__] up and that's what Bill Gates does
dude
he also uh uses experimental vaccines on
people in Africa and they grow like
extra limbs and [__] but you don't see
that in the news either which is also
true he also and you can look that up in
Business Insider or Forbes okay both
those are two published or Infowars
maybe now you care about stats and
sources and stuff when it benefits me
yes well Bill Gates did a thing where he
went to Africa and he was like hey
everyone needs to get circumcised right
now
wait I didn't circumcised a bunch of
African dudes and it didn't do anything
like it just caused infections and
people died of AIDS uh what was the
intended goal what he just was like hey
this is a better way to have a dick
wait no actually I'm wrong I I recently
yeah yeah dudes with their hoods on are
having better sex yeah in fact yeah
because you don't need as much Lube
because your foreskin
yeah it's just a sleeve so you're
basically supposed to like stay there
and then you're you're your inner dick
goes in
this is 100 True uh Infowars and
Business Insider both agree with that
but here's the thing dude you got to
realize though that it's yes they have
better sex however Kyle are you
circumcised
[__] useless
um
uh what I was gonna say though is that
at the hood that that there is lower
levels of like the hood penile cancer
and other infections in the penis if you
are circumcised
so it helps you not get painted you cut
your wiener a little bit healthier you
don't cut your winner a little bit
better sex also cut wiener looks okay so
what other part of your body like the
tonsils or the appendix my tonsils are
also taken out it's a healthy
reproductive organ what is the why would
why would we have like a reproductive
organ that doesn't work properly or do
you think like people in the Bible were
kind of weird about dicks I think
they're gonna cover that one please I
think they were complete weirdos but I
also think that you know I am
circumcised and I'm going to fight for
that right it's post-hoc rationalization
you're like this happened to me so it
must be right look I'm on I'm on that
team and that's a hill I'm gonna die I
don't know I think if I were to have a
kid in like I don't think the first
thing in my head would be like let's
remove parts of its body like yeah
like
are you pretty yeah would you circumcise
your dog
yeah would you cut a dog's balls off
that's amazing wait hold on that's a
different question though yeah that's a
different question
I'm like Hey Dad this is what I think
he's like oh yeah would you have a gun
to your head I'm like
stop it's not the argument just to win
his point
um what's the question would you Circle
no I know you wouldn't circumcise your
dog would you cut your dog's balls off
okay so you're a [__] hypocrite dude
we switched from a kid to a dog I'm
sitting their kids balls
this CR I'm against it it's not like
castrato if you wanna if you want your
kids to be a really good singer hey look
for the record I have no dog in this
race and I don't give a [__] at all
get in the game what yeah if you did
have a dog would it have balls or no uh
as long as there's no skin off my wallet
that was nice
get off my wallet hey brother I just
made that up soon
wallet you're like making wallets out of
your skin what if it's a velcro wall man
I meant as long as I don't have to pay
for it that was a the internet
I've been saying that for years I'll let
you cut my dog's balls off but only if
you do it for the love of the love of
the balls yeah what do they do with
those balls anyways I think they just
toss them out or they make like a
smoothie or something
they should recycle those balls yeah in
America we're quick to just get rid of
the parks but another country that's
going straight to the market what do you
think they do in Ireland they'd probably
pretend like they invented it right just
like the potatoes these are these
they just turn into a new potato you
know Russell balls in America that's how
they got out of the potato fan how do
you think potatoes recreate
reproduce now there's a reason they call
them spuds studs spuds spuds
I feel ostracized now that I admitted I
would cut off using so many fancy words
ever since I taught you morose morose
yeah whatever dude you're not trying to
get the definition on that one oh yeah I
know the definition hold on because it
sounds like you're new to the morose
game no I figured out through context
clues but it means you know depressing
we're gonna Genius of the house contacts
you sounded out your first thought I
actually have an English degree damn a
journalism degree and I didn't know what
that word was so it hurt especially
heinously heinously heinously but you
can you could cite like a [__]
your highness yeah dude you got strong
citation skills
um APA
limb here Chicago assume that all of us
did you go to college no uh currently I
am I'm a college I'm an ace how old are
you riverbatch okay so you're a failure
how did you go to college yeah of course
yeah proper age when a man becomes a man
I was off fighting for American freedoms
you go through American quinceanera
remember in college protesting it so
yeah
yelling baby killer when you came back
yeah I did I was over there fighting the
Viet Cong and I came back you guys were
throwing Rock
and let me into the military I tried to
get not even with that mustache they
said that my criminal record was length
dude you have a high and tight right now
I thought you just came back I just
couldn't pass the fitness test that was
my uh they uh but I went to Conroe late
I did I did graduate but I graduated
when I was 27. so I'm calling you a
failure only because real estate you got
me beat yeah are you a GED kid too no
I'm not that dumb okay no offense no
they tried to they tried to kick me out
of school and sent me to the school of
possibilities this is what it was called
digger
if you go to school at Hogwarts School
of positive room of requirements no I
did not going to school the school of
possibility
uh no I I they didn't the job of Despair
I think but
I went to school in Dayton Ohio so okay
Rob Dyrdek yeah he I went to church with
him really dead serious I didn't even
know if that was true or not and I threw
it through he was from Ohio okay yeah
he's a he's a uh I don't like him why I
just I don't like what he did to the to
True skateboarders he's a bit of a
sellout but because of the the Alien
Workshop thing been like that dude he
sold a real skateboarders company dude
capitalism I respected some Netflix
documentary I didn't watch no this
wasn't a doctor um you had to read
Thrasher Max
some of you watching a plane dude am I
like I'm bored let me you are not a
future guy weren't you fast what's that
Odd Future
uh yeah okay no dude I I just was gonna
say about the uh the workshop thing I
had a buddy that worked in that that
warehouse and um yeah it sucks to suck
that's kind of how I look at the world
in general yeah if you can piss in the
mouths of your enemies do it well if you
could piss in your own mouth wouldn't
start a war if I could piss him I would
think about it probably suck myself off
or yeah wait what am I talking about
that's what I meant I hope you can suck
yourself
I see this is why I don't drink dude but
uh all the possibilities teaches you
words of no I didn't go there they uh
they tried to send me there because I
kept getting suspended but you didn't
have the resume I spent like like
like 30 days in in school suspension my
freshman year in high school and they
were just like dude this kid's [__]
like insane he's out of control and my
mom was in the front line she was like
look you can't take this kid out of
school because if he's not in school
he's going to get out of control and be
worse and blah blah
and uh so I ended up sticking it out and
I graduated regular High School
okay that's normal most of us have done
that you want a medal no I was gonna say
that should be a requirement to be alive
uh if you don't pass high school we
should kill you I hey would you both I'm
voting yes on that post I'm going yes on
that there is two types of people that
drop out of high school like poor people
and brilliant are dumb yeah and people
that are too smart for high school so
you're right we got to let them give
them a year afterwards let's see what
direction but it's like it's like five
percent to 90 like luck or dude I don't
want those genetics in exactly poor
people yeah let's get them out of here
dude let's get him out vote him out all
my jeans actually I'd be [__] I'd be
out so no no no no until I'm on the
other side of the fence would you suck
your own dick though come on I would duh
okay cool let's make sure we're on the
same page what am I gay of course I
would what do you do that's not your
dick would taste like
uh well I got a nice apricot spread that
are scrub
would you wash your dick more
uh that's what the Irish are known for I
would probably get a more natural soap
right and then to avoid the like acidic
because I don't consider that putting up
on apricots I've never I never consider
that for the lady but for myself I think
maybe
you want to Spruce it up a little better
look it gets hot out here boys a little
humid I'm not putting that in my mouth
I've had a dream you sucked your own
dick
I'm looking deep into your eyes and I
know you you're saying from a place
you've been there I guess you're having
a Daydream just in the daytime
and then you and then you wake up and
realizes kick in your mouth yeah
I wake up in my own dick dream I've just
been thinking about it
myself I've been remembering it's real
sadly realize that's that's not your own
dick in my mouth that's somebody else's
that's a tough that's a tough pill to
swallow a tough dick to swallow really
enough come to swallow
you just stick it up there they just
need to cut penises dude you know what
I'm saying I got circumcised they'll
call back on the castrated this [__]
Lion King a baby up there what are you
what are you doing here when we're not
here what are you doing
it's me yeah nothing no I barely use
this place no one ever uses this place
unless it's for podcasts dude I'm down I
spent like a lot of work send Kyle over
here that's a good setup I like it yeah
how small it kind of like makes it feel
like we're trapped in here do you ever
try to crawl in here
we are trying have you tried like
turning off the lights and going strobes
hey I didn't read the room right
y'all want to be naked and dance
but have you no no I I think we could do
like special lights we can get like
police lights on these things a disco
ball at least well the thing is is that
it doesn't really translate on camera
that well sometimes I said that I
thought you were doing the strobe is for
the listeners I assumed you knew what
you were talking about
so I read you wrong
so what do you think about the politics
I knew another hard hidden topic was
coming I uh speaking of politics I think
uh the CIA killed uh JFK 100 that makes
sense but no but it's like I don't know
what you're talking about I'm just I'm
leaning more into that direction the
more and more I I go down my rabbit
holes what do you think the motivation
was do you think he was too left-leaning
for the hard hard-nosed right Wingers
Vietnam I mean dude there's so many
angles because the mystery he was so
right when he was like a four invading
Cube but he did the Bay of Pigs he was
for Vietnam like he was like pretty much
the best he was like the Obama like he
was I thought it was like because of his
his ties to the mafia and his family was
that's another idea why would they care
about that well that he all sudden
wanted he came out saying we're like
we're gonna go we're gonna be
hard-hitting on the mafia and start
taking out some of that leadership
within like New York and stuff right or
am I making this up well I think that
was inevitably gonna happen anyways yeah
but maybe I I thought that that was some
of the things I think it was political I
think if it was like Obama got
assassinated it's because of like people
that don't want Universal Health Care
and they want whatever that is yeah it's
more so what I think but you've spent
some time in Dallas right have you been
to the sixth floor Museum no dude
because that's where uh the building he
got shot from okay allegedly it's The
Book Depository yeah I've been on the
grass you know where I really got shot
and that was where I don't have to go to
the museum bro so but wait wait the
grassy knoll was where they said that
Harvey or [__] what the [__] Museum's
that bill the guy from The Watchmen shot
him he's a Pruder
no it's a the Pruder took the film oh no
no I thought was where the shots came
from yeah yeah that's where a shot for
sure came from because the exit wound
was in the back of his head was standing
in the Knoll did it like come from
different on the pedestal but the guy
that the uh Lee Harvey Oswald he wasn't
right he was in the sixth floor of the
Texas
depository where you deposit books yeah
did you like research basically a giant
USB stick this this topic is insane
actually it is first of all there's a
documentary narrated by Whoopi Goldberg
have you seen it whoa eat some mushrooms
and watch it it'll change everything
also you got to go to the museum Hall
you got to look out the window why did
you call it the 6-4 Museum because
that's what it's called okay why why is
it called six four because the window is
on the sixth floor oh sixth floor sorry
I'm not announcing
your thick Irish accent sorry sorry Lads
I think we were like saying like six
foot four like the six fours
I couldn't hear you yeah dude I'm sorry
I'm all right stop over here if you're
an expert on this topic which I'm going
to you are I'm not gonna okay ask a good
one right you're right I am I want to
learn have you met a man or heard of a
man named Robert Morrow Robert Morrow he
co-wrote a book with uh with [__]
that dude Stone Oliver Stone no Roger
Roger Stone
he like ran for office here in Texas he
wears a Jester hat okay the guy's out of
his [__] mind but he is the number
one
most
um
and he's the number one expert on the
JFK assassination and he well doesn't
that just work out the most insane guy
is awesome expert but he has a lot of
like really interesting info on it and
anybody watching this should check that
guy out because this book that he
co-wrote with Roger Stone isn't like
it's crazy and when I say insane I don't
mean like it's like wacky or whatever
but it has like every single [__]
thing detailed oh that's cool though
it's crazy you know before he got in the
motorcade the governor of Texas gifted
him like a big old Texas cowboy hat like
one of those traditional huge cowboy hat
and Kennedy refused to put it on because
he thought it was going to be
unpresidential
that video changes if he's wearing the
Hat fellas could you imagine that a
[__] a cowboy hat when he gets them
out with a spike to the Moon I mean
falling off imagine Jackie going for the
Hat well so I mean think about this
though you ever worn a cowboy hat right
you want one no it doesn't fit directly
on your head if he had the cowboy hat on
it's slightly elephant bullet could have
gone through the top dudes alive or
gunman just gets a little giggle right
before the shot and it's kind of fun and
maybe misses yeah I see where you're
coming from I just there's a couple
different angles here I mean that's
unrealistic I don't think that a a
political assassin is gonna laugh well
look hey you don't know what kind of
pressure that man was telling you don't
know political assassins are known for
their sense of humor fact that was kind
of a funny shot when you think you know
the guy from the the UT Tower shooting
yes was no well he would have been
[__] by the way that's yeah that's
what we're right in his wheelhouse yeah
we are in his shot don't say my address
I realize maybe bleep that out oh we're
live sorry they're gonna triangulate our
position
guy was allegedly uh just say the n word
all right dude never mind
I kind of we had a brain tumor is that
what it was yeah
he was he had a brain tumor they opened
up his head and it was like pressing
down on the part of the bread that makes
you want to shoot down
yeah learned that from waterboy what
happened did they did did he I think a
police officer went up there with a
pistol and got a shot oh yeah they
climbed this yeah enough's enough knock
it off up there what about what about uh
Charlie Manson Charles Manson never he
was acid he was created in uh San
Francisco uh all I'm saying is the Beach
Boys gave him one shot we give that boy
a record deal this never happened yeah
actually the drummer Dennis Wilson wrote
a song with him dude there's a song
called never learn not to love you that
the Beach Boys did and if you play it
slowly not slowly but if you if you just
play it and listen to it like really
focus on the chorus it sounds like he's
saying
um I'm your kind I'm your kind and I see
but it sounds like he's saying I'm your
kind of Nazi and people say that uh
Charles Manson put that in there as like
a uh like a hidden meaning of the song
yeah [__] crazy so another hitting
meeting who's the first time
that was just a hidden meaning that he
put on forehead real hit it
yeah you're right you really got to dig
for these Clues
well I'm just saying that that was he
wrote that way before but like Charles
Manson was in and out of prison his
entire life in the the CIA experiment
experimented on him in uh during MK
Ultra fact yeah he kept getting arrested
and she didn't out of jail when you hit
me with the fact dude
that's what you don't take him serious
throw him out on it I mean true anybody
watching this fact check this live and
put it in a live chat because I'm not
just making this [__] up my head I'm not
that creative hold on Chucky Manson has
he wants he's on Spotify go get your
game game
look at your game girls Charles man on
Spotify yeah it's Terrance yes he is he
was a songwriter he was friends with The
Beach Boys he thinks we're making all of
this no the parts of it maybe I think I
remember but no literally everything I
just said is a fact I'm not making that
up at all you don't believe anything I I
said you need to read more dude I do
need to read more women are better than
men because we have Charles Manson they
have Yoko Ono oh my god dude don't even
compare this I just watched 10 times
more have you guys watched have you
watched if you watched get back the
Beatles project dude she sucked they're
like in in the studio trying to make
magic and this [__] is just staring at
John Lennon like all over him just
touching his face yeah Focus think about
this now does it make sense now that you
know that does it make sense why John
Lennon used to beat the [__] [__] out
of her dude I thought you didn't say he
did not beat the [__] out of her he beat
it the [__] out of his first wife no he
beat the [__] out of his kid and Yoko
Ono and the other wife and he pissed on
a nun's head true and then after that he
gave peace a chance John Lennon was a
[__] horrible that was par for the
course in the 60s he was actually not he
didn't beat her as hard as most men did
back then that's true you know uh Jimi
Hendrix had a was in a pay phone with a
girl one time and like beat her head in
with the pay phone
I think I'm just making all this up like
if I could make [__] like that up off
the top of my head I would be doing
something else I've never felt more
connected to a human being in my life
I'm just letting you have the I'm like
that you're not the first person to say
that to me okay I take it back kids wait
I'm out so yeah I mean Yoko Ono she was
like trying to ruin the magic she was
just like lovey-dovey and just like all
about herself and her feelings or
whatever dude imagine just like like
imagine that like in the comedy club
like just imagine a girl just following
you I guess that happens
I know I'm thinking about my
relationships like [__] I need to stop
it's like I get it I get John Lennon's
position totally the wife beating or the
music the whole shebang
um no I think it's uh like if you're
like a nerdy dude growing up and then
you suddenly are the biggest fan in the
world you're like hey why don't I just
beat your wife be mine yeah why don't I
just have a woman around me all the time
um yeah I mean that's a really insecure
way of living your life but I mean the
the part I don't care about that part
the what I'm talking about is
Yoko Ono
um pulled apart a band that was trying
to bring peace on Earth and I I would
sound very peaceful
I don't know I didn't know all that
about she stopped a wife beater from
propagating us message about this sound
back
would you rather have a wife beater
who's bringing peace on Earth or would
you rather have someone who didn't beat
their wife but try to kill all the Jews
was that his wife or his side piece it
wasn't his wife okay it's just a
girlfriend okay but yeah I'm pretty sure
he was a vegetarian yeah which is also
dude ain't Adolf don't even get yeah and
he also started a bunch of like animal
rights organizations like he had this
whole thing like I'm a good guy I love
animals I don't beat my wife but then
meanwhile he's Exterminating the Jews
like you can't just take the surface
level [__] man women need to take a hit
for the Jews
yeah oh he back me into the corner here
huh I'm not gonna agree or disagree with
that sounds like according to Hitler had
his priority I'm not saying I agree with
his priorities but at least I'm saying
that organization like if you put
yourself in the shoes of a person in the
shoes of a person in the 30s in Germany
he he created this Public Image that he
was like a good guy at the time and then
later obviously people were like oh yeah
that's not good but my point is that
like people that that go above and
beyond to make themselves look good to
the public can sometimes have uh you
know
terrible [__] motives and the reason
that they might be trying to make
themselves look good to the public is
because they're just achieving what
their own selfish desires and goals are
which could be world domination and
extinguishing the Jewish race
okay
um well from our sponsors
that was pretty much a good message
somebody that like John Lennon always be
suspicious is there a connection between
John Lennon and the Nazis
you've drawn some parallels or what's
going on is that crazy that they were
just like 20 years removed from World
War II uh yeah yeah that's kind of wild
that's a good point I was like damn
that's like 2 000.
it's like 2 000 right it was like 9 11.
the Nazi sold out the Madison Square
Garden you guys seen that it is Airline
if a girl doesn't remember World War II
it's too young to [__]
she didn't live through the Battle of
Britain wait a minute
the Nazis did what message they sold out
Madison Square Garden a little win oh
yeah they had a rally and they had like
a big portrait of George Washington that
was like 30s yeah they're George
Washington yeah they used George
Washington to promote nothing they were
trying to get Nazi sympathizers in the
US I'm guessing yeah because before like
before it like transitioned to the
extermination of Jews it was just like a
nationalism thing right this is Germany
our exports will be our Imports
everything will be Germany and uh Henry
Ford was a famous Nazi sympathizer
Prescott Bush the uh the patriarch of
the Bush Dynasty uh sold steel to the
Nazis yeah and he laundered money for
them in his Banks correct there's
several several businesses that are just
a lot of a lot of NASA scientists come
from Nazi Heritage Operation Paperclip
also Declassified
back before the Nazi started doing [__]
they were just like hey we should have
like a uh you know help the business
tycoons get more money we should not do
communism we should not do labor unions
we should help like rich people get
richer and we should all you know that
uh that Hitler was like super addicted
to amphetamines right Adderall
essentially in today's terms and um they
they like they put all their soldiers on
amphetamines and steroids and just like
have them do these crazy [__]
experiments and cut off their eyelids
sounds like a U.S president they were so
out of control that like or Hitler was
like so out of control by the end of it
that he he was having ideas like he was
trying to create the first
intercontinental ballistic missiles and
they were like digging like mile long
holes into the sides of mountains to
shoot missiles across the ocean at the
U.S like they do had like these crazy
[__] ideas
um and it was all like the it was all
the result of basically like just taking
way too many adderal dude so you they
would have just mountains
imagine a mountain with the the the Nazi
like like all the research and like
crazy [__] they did is like it's so
interesting because it's like they're
when you have no ethics whatsoever to
prevent you from doing things you'll do
anything right and they just did crazy
ass [__] up [__] yeah they got
experimental out there yeah like they
did the human centipede that was German
right
what did we even get from that like
hypothermia they used to like make Jews
Like be cold
Jews only a Nazi Germany he's telling me
that is that an advertisement
get them while they're fresh you thought
their dicks were small before
I mean and the unit like 731 in Japan
was way worse they would like do crazy
[__] they would like give them diseases
and [__] in China like the Japanese
people
they would have a tit cutting
competitions and ear cutting
competitions
how do you win
just cut off a bunch make a necklace
show off to the boys so the droop the
drooling part is part of it you gotta
craft something with it yeah you can't
just a lot of people can cut a cut a tit
off but not everyone can make something
out of it how crafty are you that's what
we really want to know we don't care
about the guts
intricacy is where it's at it really is
that's what's taking over anyways so
what do you think about uh privatization
you know the word privatization was
actually coined by the Nazis to
privatize things that were nationalized
like the steel industry they're like
let's let Private Business tycoons take
it over because they didn't want to give
oh yeah and how much of our like modern
language and and technology is based off
the Nazis it's got to be a lot right
seriously some of the best Disney movies
anti-semitic but that's different than
being a Nazi a Nazi is a national
socialist the mustache was dangerously
close that's all I'm saying right
what was it did he have a like a Charlie
Chaplin maybe I think maybe at one point
I look I looked over here like we were
gonna pull it every time Kyle goes to
get us a beer I'm so [__] worried
he's gonna take a sip of one and just
[__] have a meltdown dude is that all
it takes dude it's bad yeah it's dude
it's feel bad drinking this is a good
this isn't good no no he needs to learn
dude this is a great City to be an
alcoholic maybe one of the best dude
it's literally the worst I eat what okay
no it's the worst city to be an
alcoholic oh just because of how I feel
like we have 1000 by proxy you're like
concerned for him medically so well he
lives with anything
just kidding last time Kyle drank he was
blacked out for four days half why do
you keep bringing it up why is this so
interesting to you I have to remind him
because because he was get he's doing a
beer run I'm just concerned he's gonna
like maybe freak out and bite through
the side of the can and chug it all I
don't know but like don't you think like
you're concerned for him as a proxy to
be concerned for yourself you wish that
someone cared about you the way that you
care about Kyle yeah nobody cares about
me like that it's bad dude well nobody
cares about Kyle that way you don't even
care about Kyle that way am I just doing
it for attention I'm doing that for
today yeah no I no he lives with me I
don't want to have a [__] guy
it is a selfish that's that's excuse
that's the excuse I'm using right man I
care about cows alcoholism Hans might be
onto something anytime I talk about
somebody usually so I can then just
share information I'm like oh my god did
you hear about Olivia she's freaking in
this thing and it's like I don't know
yeah so I get to share it you hear about
Harold he has a tiny dick man someone
really needs to suck tiny dicks it's
terrible no one will do it I've never
met a Herald with a big hog that is a
little big name Harold and that's shout
out to Harold sorry about that I have a
great uncle Harold never seen his dick
though so it's a good thing not again
I'm sure you blocked not everyone can
say that you see how I brought up Harold
because I was bringing attention back to
myself
no I haven't if I had I would have
brought that up because it would be
evidence to or against the argument but
I just brought it up just to make sure
that the camera was on me
you're a masterfully done beautifully
done watch this whole podcast just be a
close-up of Gary
that's how you get the job that's how
you lock it down that's the case I'm
just gonna start making sounds
nice yeah
so what do you think
what's going on dude life's been I mean
the [__] women from dude I'm a mixed
bag so I was born in Connecticut
see I'm gonna present it with some Flair
otherwise
uh born in Connecticut and I grew up uh
in California so like when I was six
moved to California and then I left when
I was 19 joined the military what part
of California though like North La
Valencia okay that sucks yeah white
Suburbia I was actually quite safe
um yeah but it was nice I mean no yeah
yeah I'm boring that goes without saying
I got no culture I've got no soul were
you from Philly I had nothing it had
nothing to do what not a single [__]
thing to do without let's say what are
you gonna say I was just saying that
California sucks San Diego that's where
he's from brother oh nice I'm here baby
I left all right dude same here you know
are you a Californian no what did you
went to college there that's where my
kid lives okay you know what I'm saying
I went there for college
and a little piece in here stood there
for her since then and now you're
liberal no no I went there and became
I probably was like okay I should have a
little bit more of conservative values
and then I went to [__] UT
and I was like holy [__] this is insane
yeah and then I became a uh Trump
supporter right wing no no I better
actually voted for a woman in the last
election Joe Jorgensen believe it or not
I know I became a Libertarian when I
went to [__] UT I was like Blown Away
by how [__] stupid everybody was it
blew my [__] mind legitimately it's a
waste of time
what is one issue that you did supposed
to do with people the most on
the one issue that I disagree with
people the most on guns for sure
people are saying that you know I can't
own a bazooka yeah that's okay why tell
me why not hurting the proof is on you
that's no no I'm with you brother
hurting the proof ain't on us then you
know what I'm saying what do you want to
hit all the countries that don't have
guns in their society that have way
better quality of life and less
shootings the only place that is better
than the United States is Japan
and it happens yeah
99 Japanese yeah so their genetics are
just Superior so you like homogeneity
you like racial only if it's Japanese
dude I think we need to convert everyone
to Japan Japanese
people that take over the world I mean
I'm just kidding but uh I don't think
racial homogeneity is like I'm from
Dayton Ohio dude I'm from uh The Gutter
and then Hans where are you from Seattle
Seattle all right Mr Holland oh not to
be confused with Mr hands who's also
more region I don't want people
if no one says Mr first names
yeah I thought I thought see I thought
oh yeah call me call me Mr Gary just say
it Mr Gary yeah it sounds like you're
gonna touch me that's the game take me
out back and teach me a lesson not into
it at all yeah but also if you called me
Mr Faust
not into that either dude no just don't
do that did you did you play baseball
did you have a Faust ball do you think I
was a [__] baseball player looking at
you yes
for the dip yeah I was uh
no you're playing a little punk huh I
slapped a couple of shots around you
know there you gosh hockey yeah I played
hockey dude I was a assistant Captain
tonsil hockey with a dude
do you guys dip on the ice you guys
spitting out there no I got kicked off
the team before I started doing Dipper
or smoking or anything like that I
remember an ice skating my assistant
coach
late first he was a real douchebag yeah
yeah it sounds like he didn't take it
everyone in your life has been a
douchebag it's crazy well I sometimes I
think I'm the common denominator that's
what I was applying what do you guys
think I'm the common denominator every
story that you start to sit like seep
out I realize why you didn't get into
the military you were like I was
suspended I don't know what happened
like I did throw knives
you even have military tattoos yeah not
at all I'm looking those are not really
not at all I'm telling you guys I got
this thing that military people get
that's what I meant I get
you look like you just got back from
Syria I don't even know if we're doing
anything over there
I mean you look like you just got back
yesterday just in Jerusalem
there you go I was studying the Jews was
that for the bloodline did you get your
what do they call a vacay
um when you get or they call it rights
of Passage that's right the free birth
right yeah that's what it is not a vacay
no dude I've never been in the military
none of these are military tattoos
you're free vacation uh I don't know why
I got this I don't remember getting it
Ace of Spades that's a military move my
Grandpa died military move and I got
this because I was almost positive I was
gonna go to prison so I wanted to have
something to masturbate too okay
worked out
you were gonna that's genius all right
dude stop that's smart stop okay I will
I was gonna keep gassing you up but also
I don't want another situation where I'm
all gassed up you know so do you get
turned on by your arm yeah like oh look
at those freckles of that hair sometimes
if I'm [__] a girl that's overweight
you should have gotten on the most
feminine part of your body my penis
your hairless thighs
what are you doing trimming how did you
know that that's bizarre you wax no not
at all the thighs are just hairless wait
how wait let's go back to that I have
hairless slides okay oh no I was using a
smart-ass size oh okay I thought just
looked you in the eyes and knew no the
only time I'm ever being honest is when
I'm stating facts and I say facts
afterwards okay and the fingers yeah I
don't know if you need it yeah you get
it dude I guess I think I've met you
before in another life maybe no out in
the streets you think on the streets I
mean we're in the same Community I think
we're running in the same shirt South
Austin uh do I live in South yeah I did
yeah okay I imagine before at the bars
or something like that maybe I've been
around the bars a lot okay I'm moving to
the east side tomorrow
uh it's he's 30. uh maybe I shouldn't
say I don't know I don't know
like uh Looking For Me Above the river
is uh the state of Nevada I have a
warrant in Nevada for a speeding ticket
I didn't pay and I I I'm not making this
up I uh facts I looked up I called them
that when we believed you I was like hey
can I pay this ticket because I got
something in the mail that said you
didn't pay your ticket I was like okay
I'll pay it I don't have a warrant they
told me I had to pay 2 000 or like it
was like 1800 or something holy crap to
get rid of the warrant and I was like
okay dude I'm never coming to Nevada
again you can suck my dick that's insane
it was like a 250 ticket and I like
forgot about it or something and it just
accrued
I'm going to get into the speeding
ticket game I'm gonna buy stocks and
speeding tickets or like you know I I oh
you take out a bond right sure I don't
know but you could owe Hans money I'm
gonna short your speeding ticket I'm
gonna find a way to whatever the over
under on me getting arrested like uh
you're like a collector yeah
dude honestly things that I've thought
about investing in one of them is
vending machines uh forgot that YouTube
thing too I was a YouTube suggested ad
for me was that nothing machine yeah you
buy buy three vending machines and then
invest it and after two months you're
saying he was getting fired up well I
know specifically Vape vending machines
oh no okay I didn't have people that are
addicted to Vapes like can't function
without them Kyle's addicted to Vapes
all the time the other day I come home
he's laying on the couch and he goes
dude I relapse and I almost said get the
[__] out and he goes no on Vapes
can we pass the Vape around here oh you
got one of those is this a flume
elf elf Edition elf bar so this one is
actually this one has a you know
technical businesses you don't support
escobars you're tasting this one if you
uh it's got a bold taste with an acidic
finish is this like wine connoisseurs
Wine Drinker hones no I don't like wine
do you like the brother I never had
right there that was very cool it was
just like a very big wine mixer are we
vaping oh sorry is that is that cool are
we all doing it yeah yeah why do you act
like I'm a comedian like I hang around
people that smoke in green rooms that's
true I and I did
yeah you're real seasoned huh
I don't mind them other people do it I
don't Vape a lot you do look it yeah it
doesn't look natural
even focused you liberal Focus I uh I I
quit smoking cigarettes that'll happen
when people laugh in your face on your
own podcast that's um if I'm gonna
apologize for anything it shouldn't Kyle
how much what this is rechargeable
you have a problem
that's insane to me you can't really
take it from him he doesn't need it hey
no more dude
that's the only one I haven't seen
smoking all you guys what the hell is
your problem but you can't refill it
it's disposable I'm sure it's great for
the environment that seems redundant
this camera this can't be recyclable it
smells like Trident no the sea turtles
are [__] yeah where is all of them
going
to sea turtles we're getting buzzed from
all those hints of trident yeah thank
you I know my gum not my not my smokes I
was thinking you look like you haven't
smoked anything ever do you do cocaine I
I I'm not that cool no that's that's why
you have a good nose still that's how
you could smell this because I could not
you receptors are all burned and cinch
my head and burn my
nerves and I'm good thank you I keep the
rotation going
I think uh smoking is a very natural act
that brings a community together these
are like Rogan salts yeah
what's the difference between smelling
salts and uh poppers okay so uh I got
you
so I've heard poppers go up the ass no
no they do no no this guy knows nothing
you guys are wrong
I smelled salt poppers I've had it's
like a little vial you just sniff it
you don't it opens up your [__] I
think that's what they say
or really hetero people like me it opens
up your [__] through the nasal
passage yeah it's a dilator like you
know how like you don't have to put
things in your eyes to make your eyes
you're in the Navy you should know that
when you were just taking it straight
with no poppers how quick from the from
the schnoz to the hole is that like do
you sniff it and you're immediately
loose
not bad immediate it's gonna crack it's
like over time
so then yeah I guess I have no idea I
was about to be confident we're about to
just spit facts I thought it hurts no I
thought point at me uh your facts guy
one thing I said was inaccurate Pax
spouse Also if anyone has done podcast I
were to guess no no no okay
have you thought about it uh no no you
know a guy I actually don't know
anything about them apparently I don't
either I thought they went up the Poop
Shoot you're thinking of a suppositor I
don't know what you're thinking that's
the only thing that goes up here
I think I think no one told you you just
put that in your head you're gay and
this is what I'm gonna assume all right
how do you guys do cocaine am I doing
that wrong too you put it on a guy's dog
you don't put it in your circumcised
like I said yeah under the lid and it
numbs it like like your girls you know
I bet it would if anybody would have the
same effect someone told me and showed
me you know you don't have to pull your
pants down when you do drugs
but if you want to have a great time it
depends how well I've never
boofed any drugs that's what you're
referring to unless it's whisking yeah
no I have a I actually have a real yeah
it's like a tampon up your ass ever no
no I always thought that was really
weird like a weird gay thing that frat
guys do because they're secretly
homosexual yeah these days it's the
straightest thing which makes no sense
I'm I'm although you're you do have a
G-spot in your butthole in your prostate
so they say
anyway you do anyone find out I'm still
he didn't say like you found no that's
yeah you sound like you discovered the
information that you only found out
you're like hey guys guess what you're
talking about it like it's an Atlantic
yeah
all right hey
I've been smuggling a prostate this
whole time that's it's a biological fact
I know yeah what what does that turn
into for women because they don't have
prostates what does their prostate turn
into is that like an over or a service
or whatever
because you know like all our
reproductive organs are like started out
as women yeah over our clits become
dicks yeah in fact oh okay never mind
and our our laws are their ovaries yeah
yeah yeah they're interchangeable
yeah well how do you think they'd make a
a transgendered woman they sh they
literally in fact shoved the dick back
inside yeah so we're talking now don't
cut it off I thought they cut it off are
you talking tacos hot dog the Taco hot
dog Taco okay male male to female right
I'm 99 sure that that's fat with baby
tortoises you can change their uh their
gender by uh just the temperature of
heat that you do when they're growing or
after this I know stuff about that
Turtles tortoises yeah they're turning
the turtle's gay dude that's true the
frogs frogs fact
well uh there's these people in uh one
of the islands in the Caribbean who turn
uh like they started out as women and
they turned into men or though they
started as men turning them women or
something is that firefest
no it's like like Puerto Rico or like
Dominican Republic
Caribbean I don't know it happens
there's like a neighborhood like for me
to Dory
I don't know
um
I
didn't see that in Puerto Rico doesn't
it feel like we should be watching a UFC
fight right
yeah I love it dude the curtains make it
happen speaking of uh
you guys ever see that video of the the
female to male male to female fighter
that fought like a transgender element
box found Fox just beat the [__] out of
these women dude it was insane it's like
gruesome and like pretty horrible to
watch perhaps what kind of woman turns
into a woman is like let me be bad for
the cause now
man am I right
men are the worst men will turn into
women so they could beat women up dude
that's a hill I would die on just to be
a bully yeah can they go through the
surgery just so they can be the toughest
guy in there yeah physical bullying I'm
not saying I'm for that I mean I meant
that's a hill
that no one heard what you said in the
first place yeah
if you're more of a valley guy I just um
I just I'm situation
grass you know whatever you know what I
mean yeah
anyways the reason I brought it up is
because you mentioned uh
we mentioned the transition and uh he
mentioned UFC fights and I just thought
that that was one of the most [__] up
things I've ever seen that people
condoned that it was like it was like
sanctioned wife bearded and wokeness
goes wrong yeah right exactly people are
getting hurt there's a physical there's
a physical effect here now I mean people
are getting beat up well yeah I mean
that that transgendered woman gave
multiple women brain damage that's
terrible
don't they all get brain damage what's
her record her record it's record
I I don't know man I was
I don't know the ins and outs of it that
much ins and outs it sounded like he
knew a lot about the ins and outs well I
forgot the name of it Fallon Fox when
you're talking about turning a hot dog
into a taco yeah cause I watched it I
watched the [__] video man started up
strong it was nasty dude yeah the
penises never look like a real penis
and I've seen in my fair share of
penises I've been transgender it looks
like an auditor Meyer Weiner penis what
about Elliot page that's the best penis
money can buy right does she have a
penis now
I think he has a schlong have you seen a
transgendered penis in real life
internet oh but but like there's levels
there's tax brackets to it yeah
because you can get botched up look at
the Cadillac of penises yeah and I feel
like Elliot page has a golden piece
you think it can make it bigger as you
pay by the inch yeah square square inch
yeah what are they gonna come out with
penis extension surgery bro all the
money all the money's going into tits
well how do we not how do we not have
that how is there not a prosthetic and
luckily you know I'm I'm okay
we weren't wondering I'm not great I'm
not gonna say I'm great but I'm okay you
know good personality dick good batting
average but I'm not I'm not an All-Star
okay
well what do you want to do you want to
should we call it how long we've been it
feels like I yeah I just realized uh I
was supposed to leave like an hour ago
over an hour ago
um
two hours ago one hour 52 minutes no I
mean I was supposed to leave at five I'm
trying to figure out who's got the
problem you were Kyle what do you mean
you're two hours late to something well
I mean [__] you dude Fair Fair Point
Checkmate you got me
yeah well thanks for having me on man
yeah thanks for coming over we're gonna
do this a lot more hopefully yeah man
thank you cheers thanks guys
Kyle
I don't know I don't he has different